hello guys my name is a [ __ ] welcome
to episode 17 of the Sparky game engine
series and we're making game engine from
scratch in C++ so last time we took a
look at basically just making one
texture and applying that to our batch
render and it was pretty good I mean
check this out we've got like a bunch of
brycey rendering and the rendering with
our little texture here and everything
is awesome and cool but what if we want
to have sprites which have different
textures so what if we want this sprite
over here to be one texture and then
this one over here to be another texture
like maybe like for example if you've
just gotten a 2d cut and top-down map
type of game you know like Pokemon or
something and you want to have a bunch
of tiles here that maybe represent like
sand or something and then water or
whatever you want to obviously have
different textures for each tile or
sprite so how we going to do that well
luckily it's not too difficult and we
can basically achieve this by just using
arrays of textures so I do not mean the
OpenGL texture array that is evil do not
use that or 3d textures none of that
this is literally having an array of
textures like a normal array of textures
okay so let's let's open up mischief
here and basically draw a few things to
explain this further so basically what
we're going to what what's going to
happen is each sprite okay each sprite
is clearly a renderable which is why I'm
just going to say each renderable is
going to have an wearable 2d of course
for now it's going to have a texture
probably a pointer to a texture okay so
it's going to have a texture object that
texture object clearly has an ID and
that's just like T ID that's what we
made it it's the OpenGL texture ID every
renderable has that so when it comes
time to render it okay remember we don't
want to render these individually if we
were rendering these all individually or
if it was a simple renderer all we would
have to do is we would have to basically
retrieve a renderable such as a sprite
so for all of our renderable x' we would
retrieve the sprite and this is kind of
what the simple renderer does right we
would check what
the sprites text ID is okay and by tax
ID really mean texture ID and we would
simply GL bind texture with with 2d gel
touch 2d that and that would be the end
of it that would be the end of it we're
not doing that though we can't do that
because we're not this is fine and then
we'd have to send the uniform through we
have to bind obviously when you do stuff
like that you can only do that if you if
it's basically followed by a draw call
of sorts so maybe like GL draw elements
would be an example right since our draw
elements happens to be drawing I don't
know up to well 50 K sprites at once
we can't bind textures for each of those
sprites because it happens in just one
of these draw calls right there's no way
to actually set buying textures in
between draw calls so what we want to do
instead is basically send them in as
attributes but then comes the question
of what if I want multiple textures how
does it how do i bind multiple textures
well all we have to do is use a little
something called GL active texture okay
so we can use GL active texture with a
number such as zero and it will just go
all the way up to 31 I think it should
go higher than that I think 80 is the
standard and there's an 80 is what the
specification says to have at least 80
but um it'll go up to like 31 let's just
quickly check so GL texture GL active
active tech shows that's clearly not it
I think it is deal of texture yes it's
just gel texture so 31 so what can you
help me out please
yeah so it looks like it only goes to 31
for some reason but anyway gel texture
31 so we set GL active texture with GL
texture and then a number and then we
can basically have up to 32 textures
bound at once with a varying sampler
right so our sampler is basically a
texture ID that we give to the shader so
it knows what to look up in memory but
what essentially happens is this sampler
will read will basically have an array
right which will contain say the numbers
between 0 31 the sprite has an ID such
as I want to use texture 17 in this
array and then it will draw it with that
texture simply by doing that and we just
bind to actually active to each of these
active GL active textures these okay
cool so that's our idea now the problem
is well there are a few problems one of
the problems you'd probably notice is 31
what if I want 50 what if I want 500
textures can I not do that really do I
have to split up draw calls the answer
is yes you do up splitter you do up to
split up draw calls but we can certainly
have more than 32 textures in our engine
that's that's not actually a problem so
that's pretty much it so what we need
the what we need our batch renderer to
do okay is when it takes a like when it
takes in a renderable when we submit a
renderable so this is the submit method
inside our batch render when we submit
something it's going to query the
renderable for its or is going to
basically retrieve the renderable x'
texture ID okay which will just be like
this for example the sorry well yeah but
the this texture the ID thing right
it'll check to see if that texture ID is
basically something that we've already
got so for the first 32
textures it'll be fine yeah for the
first 32 textures if it notices that
we're using a texture ID which isn't in
some kind of array that we've already
defined client side right CPU side if
it'll try to see if it's in this array
if it isn't in the array if this doesn't
exist it's going to have to basically
end the draw call flash everything okay
process the tax reckon it can do the
texture anywhere really but and the draw
all flush begin and then probably
process the texture and here it doesn't
really matter when as long as you do it
before the draw call so before flash but
it'll have to process a tax rate I'll
have to add it into the array it'll have
to bind it to a target and do all this
crazy stuff so that the best part about
this though is that we can have more
than 31 textures because what happens
when we hit that cap we just flush
whatever we've already got and then bind
a set of say another 31 textures okay
now will this result in more than one
draw call obviously we will basically
end up having more than one draw call
right we'll have depending on how many
how many times so basically our idea is
our draw calls will go up by more than
30 so let's just say for each 32
textures is going to go up by 1 X so if
we have say if we really want us to
write an equation for this and X is the
number of textures basically that would
be our our draw call equation kind of
right now right so every 32 textures we
go up 1 draw all except it will be
probably like plus 1 right and it'll
round down to an int or whatever but
that's our idea if you wanted to really
Express what it is now
what if we're not texturing right that's
the other thing I've covered if we've
got more than the required amount what
if we've got 0 well that's pretty easy
to do as well
we can make 0
or negative one or whatever really be is
probably zero might be a better option
because because we will deal with
unsigned but we can check to see oh if
the texture if it has no texture or
whatever we really can skip this whole
process yeah if it has no tax show we
can just say if it's if the texture ID
is zero for example yeah
just don't do this hole checking
situation all you have to do is just
continue on basically and set the
texture ID of a scene the thing to zero
and then when it comes to the shader it
will obviously see that oh you're using
a texture ID of zero thus I'll draw you
a non textured quad or something like
that okay so that's the idea is it
simple not really but it is not that
complicated either and that's pretty
much the idea but of course it's
incredibly powerful and it will let us
have almost as many textures as we want
okay basically limited by memory and
stuff like that okay fantastic so let's
begin in our sprite or the first thing
I'll probably do is go to renderable and
I'll give every renderable a texture
okay just a texture pointer like that
we'll also have a we can make this in
line cost whatever an inline Const so
we'll have an inline Const called
something like I don't know Glu Glu int
get tid okay so there'll be our texture
ID that we want to retrieve so what that
will do is it actually has to do a few
things it has to basically return so it
might return zero okay it will basically
check to see if I definitely should call
this M texture
it will check to see if M texture is a
null pointer if so well we are returning
an unsigned at this point so we'll say
something like let's return 0 else will
return M texture dots or arrow get ID ok
which I'll have to add to the texture in
a minute ok that's our basic plan is
pretty simple so that means that if we
do encounter something that is 0 that
means that we don't want it to be
textured at all so we are still
supporting the fact that oh maybe I just
want to draw a solid color not a texture
right that's we still want to we still
obviously want to want to support that
we don't want to have to make a texture
that's a solid color for example every
time ok cool so now that we've done that
if we go into texture real quick an add
all of our cool stuff such as get ID
which will just return that we should be
ready to party so in bash renderer this
is where the fun stuff happens so when
we the other thing that I should mention
is that all of the binding of textures
all of all of that like stuff of which
active texture do we want to use all of
that stuff all of the uniforms all the
samples all the setting the samplers
that is what the renderer does remember
we want to keep the renderer the
renderer is like this weird sad creature
that does all the work and we don't care
we're making a slave away for us and
then everything else is so much higher
level everything more is just so much
higher class right it just it's that it
basically is like hey renderer here's my
texture do something with it I want to
drawn for this bride at this location
right we that's kind of how it and
that's kind of how it works so we don't
want to do anything like that
ok all this all this stuff no that
doesn't exist we want to make a new
sprite we want to pass an either protect
object or maybe even just a path and be
like I want this to use this and then
it's and then again all the sprite will
do is just set it to the field the
sprite is
almost the sprite is almost just like a
plain old data kind of object that just
has a bunch of data grouped together in
what we call a sprite or a renderable
right and then the renderer is what is
like oh I have to somehow drawl its
texture I better figure out the great
thing about this is that the renderer is
actually the thing doing the drawing the
renderer is one of the only things that
is actually API specific or we check if
we choose to change this into DirectX
right the renderer is one of the only
things that should actually be affected
okay
all this other stuff we are using now
the only stuff that we really if we just
go and look at renderable for example
the only thing that we're really doing
which is kind of flat formed apparel
like API dependent I should say stuff
like GL u int okay that is just a data
type we can easily change that or define
that somewhere else and if you just
check it yourself really all the UN is
is an unsigned int that's it okay that
is all it is is typed after right here
so that's kind of all we're doing and if
you look through this again it has
nothing to do with OpenGL apart from
that again the texture does the actual
textual loading does but apart from that
is just the bat renderer this is
obviously all API specific but that's it
so it's a good idea to kind of plan your
engines or whatever to be kind of API on
specific okay you want it to be you want
to not really care about what API uses
up until the actual implementation of
the renderer which is this okay so now
that we've covered all that we can
probably begin and actually make this
work so when we're submitting all this
stuff we want to be able to retrieve so
conce Glu int I'll call this T ID right
texture ID
what is it renderable guess t ID okay so
when we get this we want to basically
check out a few things first of all this
color code that we do all this maths
that we're doing here doesn't actually
need to exist if we're using a texture
so clearly we don't want to do that so
we want to basically say if texture ID
is greater than zero that means we're
valid that means we're going to do a
bunch of texture stuff else well we'll
probably do stuff like this and actually
render it
differently okay but that's kind of the
idea for now and you can see this color
will scream at us we don't care okay
that's the idea in fact we can just
probably set color up here or something
to be just for now at least so it
doesn't describe it us unsigned and C
equals like zero or something
okay and then we'll just get rid of this
okay so if we're valid it wins it means
that we're actually using what is a
valid texture so what we need to do is
find it in our texture slots so we need
to set up some kind of array as I
mentioned which has all of that texture
slots and this is going to be quite a
smart array because inside this array we
have two things okay
generally when you create a raise you
actually have believe it or not per
value you've actually got two sets of
data you've got a key and then you've
got a value so if I'm like I want an
array of names and I say let's just put
in two names that index zero the name
Cherno for example and that's my array
of names we have two pieces of data for
this we've got the name which is the
value okay and then we've got the key
which is what we use to refer to that
particular value right the key in this
scenario is going to be our actual
sampler ID the great thing about sampler
like the the great thing about sampler
tooties i'd like IDs is essentially the
fact that they start at zero and they
just go up to like 31 or whatever they
are linear they have nothing to do with
texture IDs whereas when we actually
load texture IDs and whatnot you
actually want to be able to basically
bear different right we might load five
textures okay and then we might use text
number zero three and what am i doing
zero three and like four or something
okay that means it's not the same so we
might want we might want to link sampler
ID zero to texture zero one two three
and two to four so basically what I'm
saying is the opengl tax rate
we'll have nothing to do with they're
not in really chronological order okay
but this is always going to be from zero
one two three all the way to 31 that's
how it works okay it's that simple so
when that happens we want to set
remember that that's the other beautiful
thing about it we want to set whatever
we choose here
so basically sprites themselves don't
actually have like what's called a
texture ID they don't have like this
sampler ID thing that I'm talking about
they have an actual texture okay what
sample what sample let me just quickly
include texture as well what the sample
slot that it actually refers to is
completely set by the actual renderer
okay it has nothing to do with with the
renderable right it doesn't know what
sample it's like I want this texture
drawn you figure it out renderer okay
and the renderer has to figure it out so
the idea is this render does batch
renderer let me just get rid of almost
everything else because I don't like
seeing a lot of things around me class
wise in batch render what we'll do is
we'll have a vector of GL EWTN's okay
which are basically going to be our
sampler so we could probably call this
something like M texture slots okay what
happens is when we look at something we
need to immediately see like if we can
find this texture ID in our samples
sample slots so back to our awesome
diagram I told you that all this stuff
links so if we have let's just say we've
got three sample slots right we've got
three entries into our texture slots
array yeah here they are 0 1 2 this
corresponds to texture ID 0 this
corresponds to 3 this corresponds to 4
ok so when our sprite comes in for
rendering so this is our sprite yeah and
it has a texture ID
of I don't know it wants texture id3
this is an OpenGL texture ID nothing to
do with samples or anything like that we
need to search our array and be like oh
we want here it is we found it it exists
okay it does have a sample it applied to
it that sampler set via a uniform
everything is great okay
when that happens this sampler ID is
what we apply to the the buffer our
buffers like texture ID thing it gets
okay
it's got number one applied to it which
means the texture OpenGL 283 will be
rendered when the sprite gets rendered
okay that's how it's going to work there
are a few things we need to talk about
which is for example how okay well the
next scenario is probably like what if I
want tid 5 is that in here no I need to
add it okay so I need to say I've got 0
1 2 and then suddenly 3 ok that's a
thing now I need to add that and it will
be 5 ok which means that I need to take
my list and I need to push it into the
shader again ok by a uniform call which
is another kind of scenario that we need
to talk about ok cool all right cool so
there we go
that's pretty much all I wanted to say I
think so in this implementation we're
going to say so let's make a quick
search thing that basically looks for it
so found is going to be false we're
going to say for each of our we want to
have I here because we need to know what
the texture slot essentially is so we
might make say a we'll probably have it
as a so tip texture slot ts probably
have it as a float because we'll pass a
flowed into the shader just because it
doesn't like it's too much
let out later as well but M was it
called again texture slots
size I plus plus
and then I think okay yeah so this is I
guess we'll just yep so we need to set
okay so we'll go ahead and we'll say
that if M texture slots I is equivalent
to the tester ID that we've requested
which is this one okay means we found it
so we should set found equal to true we
should break and we should definitely
set our PS equal to say float I right
okay so there's the index because
remember the index of this thing is
acting like our actual our actual
sampler okay so if we do find it okay
this is this is the second round of
things if we do that we if if we do find
it okay it's just going to be as simple
as we found it with this should probably
be outside by the way so zero we
probably don't yeah okay we'll do that
so this will remain zero if that happens
and watch out for however but if we do
find it then we simply have to go ahead
let's quickly jump into our actual
buffer which is our vertex data we'll
jump in there and we'll go ahead and
just add a unsigned int or a Glu int the
end of the really matter I'll just keep
it as an unsigned int though I think T
ID so that means texture ID okay and
we'll have it right over here again
it'll be the four color as well and then
in our batch render LCVP will just add
in love to have one more attribute which
is tid which will be index r2 and then
we'll move this 2x3 right so there we go
those are our things for now will enable
tid so we have two passes in as an
attribute of course not a uniform
because it's going to happen like in the
middle of draw calls for each vertex not
we're not splitting up drop or sale we
can't use uniforms it's going to be just
one it's going to be a jail flirt and
it's going to have the offset of T ID
okay that's it
looks pretty good so and I know I made
it an unsigned end but I'll change that
to be a float okay so back out here in
our batter and row now we've done that
again if this does go smoothly where are
we
if this does go smoothly then all we
really want to do is basically set the
texture ID to be our what is it texture
slot right TS that's it
okay we want to do that for each of our
things okay now what we don't want to do
is well by setting it to zero we have to
then in our shader be like the texture
is zero that means he doesn't want to
use a texture let's not use a texture
right we have to do that if it's one
will probably use texture slots 0 and so
on and so forth okay so it'll just be
one of those things that we do okay cool
so everything's looking good it's okay
so you've found again if if it's found
we don't need to do anything because TS
is now set to whatever it is and we can
continue on with our lives now if it's
not found this is where the problems
begin because we need to update our list
of texture slots so fix the scenario
this is the first time you've run the
renderer it's got zero sprites and
attach a slot in fact textures class is
just empty so clearly found is going to
be false but we want to use a texture ID
what we need to do is end the current
batch of rendering okay because we need
to set a uniform so we might have
rendered stuff that did have to hid of 0
so we might have run it a bunch of
colored talents before but now we've
actually got textures to render so we
have to end it okay
we have to flush whatever is left so in
fact we should flash first and then end
probably since that's usually the way
that we work I know hang on we have to
what I'm maps the buffer and does so we
do need to end first ha but we haven't
been doing that have we and that's been
honored the submission that's right
sorry my bad because I was going to be
really surprised at the render or
somehow managed to work well the buffer
was still mapped but so we end we flush
and then we begin again now flush is
what should update these texture slots
ok so we want to basically again if the
texture slots don't really like if the
texture slots don't if if they haven't
been exceeded there's really no reason
to actually set them up like that okay
what I mean by that is let me just think
this through
so yeah so to avoid like performance
considerations as well the other thing
we should do is we shouldn't really do
this if we like I guess we we probably
shouldn't do this if we actually like if
we actually just need to put one more
texture in because all we should do that
is a flee or something well what we
should do and still flying around you
thing go away what we should just simply
do if we still have spaces just add it
into the array because remember all we
have is will probably have a specific
amount of texture slots we want to just
simply add the new texture slot in there
so that we now have it as long as it
isn't above say 32 and then we don't
have to do this so we need to only do
this remember we that the reason we even
do something like that is only if we
actually run out of Tasha slots and we
have to resubmit a uniform that's the
only reason we do something like that
so if the size of our texture slots so
what is it M texture slots if the size
of our texture slots is basically
greater than or equal to our max which
is say 32 again we'll declare that as
like a hash define or something then we
do need to do this stuff and we do need
to have flush and all the good stuff to
it well I mean it'll do it anyway but we
need to actually push back so uh yeah
I'll explain how this works in a minute
but we need to push back our new texture
slot that we've basically decided to do
which again that will just append
something and it'll just be like 31 or
something I doesn't really matter we
just simply append a texture to it such
as where's our texture ID
test ready all right so we push back the
sash ready and then we set the texture
slot to just be the index of em texture
slots dot size minus one and we should
probably cast that to a float as well
oops okay there you go so that's all we
need to do okay and then we have the
rest of the spin and you get as you can
see it's added it and is appended and
everything is just the best now okay so
the problem begins here on doesn't
really begin here but now we need to
somehow figure out how all of our
uniform samples are actually going to
get transmitted into our shaders so if
we just try this right now what we're
going to end up with is a bunch of
textures loss which will basically be
appropriate to uniforms but they won't
have the proper textures might not be
bound at this point that's where it gets
a that that's where it kind of gets a
bit tricky okay
and we might have to actually well we
will have to bind the appropriate
textures probably in something like
flush I imagine so when you're about a
flush you need to check to see which
ones are in use bind them to their
appropriate to their appropriate targets
and do something like that so for
example we probably want to do something
like and then to make it even more
complicated it probably has different
there probably are different shaders per
yeah that that becomes a touch annoying
hmm when you think up a way that to make
this so that it's not too slow okay so
shader side let's maybe start with the
shader side as well we've got a so let's
update these right color is now three UV
is still one we now take in a float
called tid which is our texture eighty
and that's it location two we pass in a
texture a tidge like that and we'll
update that to include that
okay now a fragment shader is going to
take that in and basically this sampler
of text which we'll call textures might
be like say 32 which is I think the more
probably not the max but it's probably
the max that we can we can have hmm and
then we'll go ahead and just basically
say that if so okay we whatever we do
our lighting calculation let's get a
completely new color which will be our
tax color so we'll look up a texture
okay so we've got tax color and we'll
set it equal to some kind of default so
maybe so we'll set tax color equal to FS
in color okay
that's maybe if we don't want a on fat
we can probably just so we've got up I
don't want FS in color
mmm let's get rid of this so text color
yeah so FS enter color and then if we
decide so if FS en dot ti-ti D is going
to be greater than zero okay it means
that we've set it to like one or
whatever and we want to do this what we
should do is we should basically have
color text color be set to texture the
okay so textures and then we need to
look up a need to grab a tid this needs
to be an int though so I'll just pull it
TR tid will set it equal to an int best
way to do this without ruining
everything because it might get cost
downloads and whatnot is just say FS n
dot tid plus 0.5 okay if we do that it
will just basically the dissing or Mille
class will just floor it and we were
end up with potentially going down to a
texture ID below what we have a real
lose precision or some ridiculous stuff
so this is just a nice safe way to
ensure that we actually get the right
integer from our float we'll look up the
texture ID and then the texture
coordinates will just be FS n dot UV
which is what we used before anyway okay
so there we go we've set it in the
exceptional circumstance that we
actually do want to texture okay now out
here all we do is instead of this of
course we just use tax color so right
now what it will do is it will basically
fall back to the color if we specify no
texture okay so it should still work
correctly if we do something like I
don't know if we if we decide to
hmmm let's cover a geillis let's break
this down a bit because this is actually
not true not as simple as I thought it
would be let's go ahead and just assume
that they've all got one shader so what
we'll need to do in that case is well
it's not that yeah okay so what we'll do
is in batch render and the flash will go
ahead and will go through because
remember the shader doesn't need to get
changed
we just need to rebind everything so for
in I equals 0 I is less than M what is
it M texture slots stops sighs I plus
plus we'll go ahead and we'll set the
active texture should be GL texture 0
plus I now these are all in a row by the
way if you look at this you can see it
goes 0 1 2 3 4 5 and all the way up to
31 which is D F right so they're all in
a row which means that we can just
simply use plus I with them we can do
the same thing we can do the same thing
for our um which is f right yeah well
for our texture slots so when we call
something like GL bind texture gel so
this is actually the tip this is the
real texture that we're binding now so
we need to bind the texture which is
essentially M Texas loss I all right
that is the OpenGL texture the index is
the U is the uniform sampler essentially
so now that we've got all these bound
one thing we need to guarantee is that
and the best thing about this is that
when we're going through these we're
going through all the sizes and we're
yeah so this this will become a problem
if we actually end up having too many
textures so we'll tackle that problem
when it actually comes up but for now I
think we'll just go into our shaders so
when we create our shaders
that's probably gonna be the best place
to do that yeah so we okay so we'll go
enable I don't really want to do this
here I won't do this here
we'll have to think of a better place to
do this eventually but let's go ahead
okay we need to add so how do we I
forgot them how to how to push textures
to our arrays so what I'm what I meant
by that was how to push arrays into our
shader so let me just quickly google
that mm-hm
actually I might have it over here
okay so actually I am
okay so now hmm yes I think we can just
use set uniform like one IV or something
or Fe so in our shadow probably have to
modify that to include it by the way so
if we go ahead and just say 1fv
we'll need an array of floats they'll be
fully the count we'll just use install
sighs I I think so GL sighs I is just
unsigned int I'm guessing oh no it's
just an int oh really
so it can be negative hmm interesting
okay so we'll do that we'll copy one F
I might actually pop this in this order
I'll even make more sense that way to
specify what you want first and then
account so one Fe except sliding over in
jail takes it in this way yes it does
and if we pull out into here we'll just
switch these along okay great so now
that we've got that and that are all go
away all we have to do is basically make
a bunch of text IDs in fact sorry they
do have to be ins because they're
samplers so roll will make IV as well
and value they have to be unsigned we
won't know we won't make them unsigned
so value will be that this will be I and
then ah that's pretty much it so we'll
have to go back here obviously and clean
this up all right cool oh it's fantastic
so now what we have to do is when we set
up our shader such as this one we
actually need to do a few things really
all we need to do is make a bunch of tax
IDs so we could just say int or GL int
or whatever text IDs equals 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 you just do you just make a for
loop do this obviously and we have to
once we've enabled it we need to
basically just go shoot it out set
uniform 1iv to the name being textures
and the count and the value being tax
IDs and then the count being all in this
case 10 right and that's it
so now that we've got that and we can
get rid of text now because that's no
longer a valid thing now that we've got
that everything should be the best yeah
okay so let's try this out
let's if we just run this now we should
just get a lot of problems here in timer
what why is it suddenly
hang on
why is this suddenly kilts out why is
this suddenly kill itself it seems to it
what the Frick look at this output of
the better
aha
maths know their warnings that rounder
oh here we go
so I don't know why timer is
particularly affected by these little
warnings anyway so all the arrows are
actually in timer why that seems to be
some kind of inclusion problem or
something but that's weird because time
I shouldn't be affected by it at all
what the Frick has just happened that's
not real our fear that it's so weird
it's clearly a thing hmm
that's yeah I do not know I must have
done something pretty silly there um
track down this problem
so timer is just like committed suicide
apparently for what seems like no
specific reason like it's not that
actually it's just the entirety of
Windows
age what what what have happened hmm I
must have done something bad
let's see I like the Frick
what did I do
that is so weird and is are weird that
is so weird
then what it must not be timer there
must be something else going on let me
just not include timer and will will
kind of get rid of it and see where else
the problems are because it's a bit hard
to track it down like that so it will
get rid of that and that okay let's
build this now
what what
what that is so weird that is so weird I
want to have to take a look at that in a
minute okay so if we pass in no textures
if we pass in no textures we'll figure
that out in a minute but I just want to
finish this when we pass in no textures
we should get our original colors which
is looks like what we we actually get
but if we do pass in a texture the way
we do that first of all is by actually
setting up a texture for renderable so
we don't have that yet let's let's do
that though so in sprites I'll probably
just make another constructor it takes
in instead of color it'll take in just a
string well
now I'll make it taken in texture always
a lot to load it all time so color we'll
just set to math spec for so we'll set
it to pink which means that it's
obviously not rendering correctly if
that's the case but in sprites and I had
a file
I will make a texture here and then we
will yeah everything else looks pretty
good I think
wait what I do
I added the texture well yeah so we need
to actually set the texture see so we'll
go ahead and set em texture to texture
right what where's our interval
was okay empty extra right that's a
thing and why can't I set it
I'd probably just set it here okay so
what we'll do is we will yep so we'll
okay so when we add the tail so we'll
create our texture which was up here we
don't need to do any of this active
textures of we do not need to bind the
texture we just recreate the texture
here it is do we specify color yes we do
I kind of wanna keep that though if I'll
just how about I just comment it out
okay so we've got our texture now one
thing in batch render actually which I'm
pretty sure I did yes so we need to
basically make sure that we're still so
remember texture slot zero means use
zero which means don't use anything but
texture slot one means we actually do
want to use something so when we do this
and when we set up the texture slot here
it should basically be I plus 1 right
because we want to because we want to
because 0 means that it's still like a
disaster everything so actually to be
honest I artists let zero zero shouldn't
be that though hey I'm going to hang on
a minute yeah so we bind that to
whatever the first slot is touchless I
so texture slots I will be zero
hmm I don't think we need that oh well
we know we definitely do because as it
back to zero but I mean that that needs
to be there but it should be a plus one
and that's our Taoiseach slot so texture
slot one means active texture zero
basically is that does that seem legit
that's totally fine yeah okay cool so I
was just making sure because it didn't
make sense in my head with now adults so
get back in there so when we do this now
why you you're so sad for some reason
what's the problem it has a role um
maybe let's just read what the problem
is oh let's make it on me so we'll have
to delete our texture separately by the
way because we might want to have the
same data for multiple slots sprites
let's quickly fix this as well our timer
was quite sad now we'll just move this
to like here it should be happier there
we go
okay so we're running pretty fast we
seem to be getting a black screen which
is not what I had hoped for
ah I'll texture is test and everything
else looks pretty good
so hang on okay so we're rendering the
layer that's right yep that's that's
totally best then over here we're
setting texture ad texture slot let's
just step through this real quick so di
D is one that's good
there's premiere all the shade a bit
hang on okay so it didn't find it the
size is not that so pushed it back and
it's now zero good white lulz it's not
just be +1 shouldn't it so it's one
that's going to set it up as one okay so
if we just quickly launch this and see
what problem is okay so problem let's go
into our shader real quick and see
what's going on there
shader okay so we're taking the vertex
we're looking in tid to the vertex
shader here's our tid if arty ideas
written 0 to X right that's really okay
so what is tid I wonder so the best way
to debug shaders is to not debug shines
but in all seriousness the best way to
debug shaders is well the only way to
debug shaders is to make it print colors
for you so let's just see what the ID is
should be all red it's not it's it's
error in me
okay they're all red good so that makes
it believable if we divide this by point
five it should be oh it's still red that
means it's that's not good
so what does tid tid is pretty beat then
I just I'm an idiot actually that's also
possible okay I you are mean okay there
we go
so we know that tid is basically one
we've confer with we've confirmed that's
the case so we'll go ahead and so what's
it
so that will set it back to a sampler
zero yes
so that's correct now sorry it was wrong
before that'll set it back to sampler
zero which will we should work
so now let's uncomment that line and
voila our texture so if we go back to
main and we try this with more than one
Tasha it should work up until 32 where
problems will begin so out here we are
so let's make another texture test to
PNG I'll call this B so where's where's
our here is so we'll just copy and paste
s lazy and we'll call this 11 with
paint.net we'll just make this like a
smiley face or something maybe in like a
nice this kind of color
that is definitely a smiley face slow
there you go
24-bit which probably add support for
more than 220 for bit dashes so t be
texture be ta tha so I guess we'll just
go round mod 2 equals 0 ta else TB
okay cool so that seems to work pretty
well let's also try it with three I
don't really want to try it with 32
that's going to take away too long you
probably call this T so at this point
I'll just make an array but yeah
textures but now we need them this so
it'll be an array of texture pointers
sorry new texture test ing okay and then
we'll just go textures round on three
okay
now we don't have TC yet so let's save
this as TC and let's change this to
something else maybe a gradient how
about that fancy where are my tools my
tools gone maybe maybe I just can't see
them
yeah there they are gone okay
radiance maybe yeah okay that's girls
whatever and then I'll change this to TV
it's fine actress anything doesn't
matter we should go through them and
delete all of them whatever yeah three
different textures okay so this will
work for a lot of things so there's a
few things wrong with this first of all
we're not we're only in we're only
initializing up to nine of these and you
can see in the shader that we've got
considerably more but the other thing is
the shader doesn't actually do that so
we probably should have the shader we
should probably have a function in the
shader that does this stuff for us so it
likes something like initialize tax IDs
and it will do like as many as you
specified so you might pass in something
like I want the name textures and I want
ten of them and it will just be like
okay I'll set the uniform textures to
zero one two three four five seven eight
nine right
so it might be something I've asked also
a also I think we're pretty much good
above that I mean if I decide to add
something like if Rand mod
four equals zero I might actually just
do this
else I'll do that so now we have our
regional stuff which is all blue and
stuff now wait a minute
seems a bit wrong
I know it's right it's just oops it's
just I looked weird without lighting
that's all so that's out lighting where
is this okay cool cool so we've got
these little varying shades of red or
whatever we've got textures we've got a
lot of this stuff going on of course our
render is still running extremely fast
let's quickly set up releasing mode for
this because I don't think we've done
that yet mm no we haven't
so I think free image and whatnot are
just not in there so out here in line in
directories and whatnot I'll have to
probably add oops the other way around
we want to add that stuff yes we want to
add that stuff and then an input we want
to add all that stuff I think that's it
right we didn't have any preprocessor
macros or anything defines No okay
there's release mode let's run it good
everything's working and performance is
as you can see over 6,000 frames per
second which is very fast for rendering
all this and you can see the tailors are
good so we didn't really test texture
overflowing we'll do that probably
sometime in the future because I cannot
be bothered testing that many textures
right now in fact you guys can test if
you like it's not going to work I don't
think so no but we'll do that another
episode this episode of watch along
anyway but anyway that's the idea Oh a
breakpoint you say let's do this quickly
do it the proper way
okay and there you go all right cool um
any questions leave them below and next
time we're going to I don't know you
know what well I was going to plan out
and do fonts next time but I might do I
might do overflowing yeah we'll probably
do fonts next time so if you guys liked
this episode please like button I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you